but because of the nature of his
evidence and the likelihood that he may
mention matters which could
potentially identify him
there will be no YouTube and there will
be no live stream
so those who are watching online
uh I'm afraid you will not be able to
access that evidence though of course
they will in due course be a transcript
um he'll appreciate those of you who are
here that I'm saying that for the
benefit of of others but they're likely
to number rather more than we have in
this room
um sizable though today's audience is
now in a moment or two um I'm going to
to ask sapner to invite each of you in
turn to take the oath
and then miss Richards will ask the
questions
if at any time
you want a break or you want people to
speak more loudly because I think Linda
you may have some
difficulties of of hearing on occasions
yeah
and you can hear me all right can you
okay
right well we'll we'll take it slowly I
hope and if I ask anyone to slow down it
is so that you can follow
um and have haven't restrain
too much
um so sapner
please State your full name
Elizabeth Mary buggins repeat after me
I do solemnly sincerely I do solemnly
sincerely and truly declare and truly
declare and affirm that the evidence I
shall give and affirm that the evidence
I shall give shall be the truth shall be
the truth the whole truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth and
nothing but the truth thank you
please State your full name Brenda
haddock take a book in your raised hand
under the Pea talk to me I swear by
almighty God I swear by almighty God
that the evidence I shall give that the
evidence I shall give shall be the truth
shall be the truth behold
the whole truth and nothing but nothing
but the truth
please State your full name Christine
Linda williscroft
book in your right hand and repeat after
me I swear by almighty God I swear by
almighty God
nothing but the truth
we know from what you've just said that
your first name first given name is
Christine but you are normally known as
Linda
start by asking Elizabeth some questions
Elizabeth you're here to talk about the
treatments of your three sons at
Birmingham Children's Hospital I am
um and your first son Richard was born
in 1978. he was
how did it come about that Richard was
diagnosed with
well and the GP referred him to the
local hospital who then shipped him from
where we lived near Birmingham up to
um older hay Hospital in Liverpool with
a police escort
and staff on board because he was so
poorly and there was something wrong
with his brain but they didn't know what
and it took three days for Richard to be
scanned
and then they realized that he got a lot
of bleeding in his brain and there was
so much blood they couldn't see where it
came from so they operated
and excised a large part of his brain
and he just about pulled through
and began to get a little bit better and
then a following week I recognized the
same look on his face as a week
previously
and so they scanned again and realized
that he'd believe that he bled again
um and they took him back to theater
he was very very very ill obviously at
that point and I think the second bleed
had resulted from a subdural tap which
they'd done at older hay before moving
him to Walton hospital
and it was only two days after that when
it looked as if it was happening again
that I was told that Richard had been
found to have severe hemophilia
and that was the cause of the bleeding
it wasn't an aneurysm that had broken or
a cancer which had tapped into a major
blood vessel in his brain
and Richard was left with some cognitive
and physical difficulties following the
events you've described he was when he
came back from Liverpool which was four
years four months later
he had
um he was more or less paralyzed on one
side his sight was very very poor but he
could hear
and and the joy for me
was that every time I went into a room
where he was he put his hand up
and um he was always pleased to see me
you had two
um two further Sons Jonathan and Edward
and Jonathan born in 1980 and what year
was Edwards born in 1981 and they too
were diagnosed with severe hemophilia a
they were
um and did you have any family history
of Hemophilia that you were aware of
none and we can go back many decades
nobody has any sign of Hemophilia but
once genetics came along
um it seems that I'm the start of the
tree rather than having a history
um
photos of the boys
um that would just show at this stage of
your evidence
so if we could have those up on screen
please Lawrence the Elizabeth's photos
so this was Jonathan sitting on the
homemade truck and Edwards his younger
brother pulling him and it's probably
about the age Jonathan was when he
acquired HIV
and this was Richard
um probably about four or five years
into his life yeah
and this this is the three boys a few
months before Richard died
and then with one more photo which shows
your
and then after Richard died I had a
daughter
and um she was quite Keen that I showed
this Photograph because it shows how
young I was
thank you Lawrence
um so the ongoing care of of Richard
Jonathan and Edward team of philia took
place at Birmingham Children's Hospital
and the consultant was Dr Frank Hill it
was
your husband was working full-time you
had been working in the health services
in a managerial role a role you later
went back to but you gave that up to
look after the children at this point in
time
and so as a result you were dealing with
the vast majority of the hospital
appointments and the treatments I was
and and so with three children with
hemophilia a um were you at the hospital
a lot a huge amount yes I've lived there
for a month at a time
um because Richard had um he was a high
responder Inhibitors with factor eight
and so and the bleeding was very
difficult to control
Richard was cheated from a very young
age with factor eight concentrates
do you know in Richard's case whether
they were commercial concentrates NHS
concentrates or a mix
I think they were almost exclusively
well I know they were always exclusively
American concentrates because he needed
so much volume of treatment
and we'll we'll look shortly at when
Jonathan began to be treated but at this
point in time with Richard being treated
and and then Jonathan and what what if
anything did you know at the outset
about risks of transmission of viruses
from the concentrates I don't remember
anything from the outset we were just
hugely believed that there was something
that could stop this bleeding that was
so traumatic for Richard
um once we arrived at the Children's
Hospital and I don't know which year
this was it's just too long ago
um but somewhere I would say between
before 1984 I remember having a
conversation about the risks of
hepatitis in factor eight of and that
there was a more of a risk with
concentrate although I never remember
that being Quantified
um but that was the extent of it really
and and at this point in time in
whichever year it was in the in the in
the in in the first years of the 1980s
were you told anything about the
seriousness or otherwise of hepatitis no
I don't think so
um it seemed a much lesser risk
and it wasn't it wasn't really talked
about explicitly until I think 1985 when
the boys were given hepatitis B vaccine
now
um Jonathan began to be treated with
concentrates also at a very young age
yes
um and we can pick that up from a report
from Professor Savage which details
Jonathan's treatment so Lawrence could
we please have witn1021004
if we go to the second page
we can see it's a report
concerning Jonathan's treatment it's
dated this is on the last page we don't
need to go to it now second of June 1992
from Professor Savage and is it right to
understand this was a report prepared in
the context of legal proceedings that
you were bringing against the health
authority it was
and we can pick it up towards the bottom
of um this first page on the screen
um there's reference to uh to Richard
um and the complications of inhibitors
um and then we can see uh the last 10
lines or so on screen this says in
relation to Jonathan the child
experienced his first clinically
significant Hemorrhage on the 13th of
February 1981 with a bleeding to the
left ankle joint he was treated at the
hospital with three packs of
cryoprecipitate with good effect
on the 27th of March 1981 the boys
sustained an injury to the left leg with
bruising of the upper third and from
treatment records it would seem that the
child was given 234 units U.S commercial
factor eight and just pausing there just
to get a sense of it and without giving
details of dates of birth Jonathan would
have been in the region of a year old he
was pointing time
and so Professor Savage continues as
possible as cryoprecipitate treatment of
infants was the recommended policy of
the hospital and indeed nationally the
administration of this large donor pool
commercial material in preference of
cryoprecipitate or NHS concentrate
without authorization was negligent
there's then a reference to a further
administration of armor Factory
concentrate in March 81 another one in
May 81 and Professor Savage continues
and this is five lines from the top as
before there is no evidence that
authorization was given to depart from
hospital policy and it is remarkable
that a different batch of U.S material
was given
there's then a bleed treated with
cryoprecipitate and then a similar bleed
treated with armor concentrate further
details of armor concentrate being given
and then further occasions in which
Jonathan was treated with
cryoprecipitate
um and if we look
uh towards the bottom of the page
yes I'll pick it up about seven lines
from the bottom but Professor Savage
says this on many of the occasions when
cryo precipitate was given the patient
was not admitted to a ward indicating
that convenience of administration of
factor eight concentrates over
cryoprecipitates possibly obviating IP
admission was not a cogent argument for
their usage during 1983 the boy was
treated on 26 occasions exclusively with
armor factor eight both as an inpatient
and outpatient during this year nine
different batches of the armor products
were used during 1984 the boy was
treated on 17 occasions initially until
and then there's a date in May with
armor and then exclusively with NHS
factor eight and it suggested that was
due to an allergic reaction to armor in
May of 84 and then in 1985 only NHS
material was used come back to the issue
of the htlb 3 testing but if we just
look further down the page
um we can see Professor Savage
expressing an opinion about the way in
which Jonathan had been treated he says
just above the heading one use of large
donor pool U.S commercial concentrates
we'll see that Professor Savage says
there are several issues in this case
which are Divergent with established
clinical practice one use of large donor
pool U.S commercial concentrates and we
can see that Professor Savage reiterates
that cryoprecipitate would have been the
recommended form of treatment
um on top of the next page
he explains why uh when he says
cryoprecipitate was a particular benefit
in such cases since it was derived from
single voluntary donor plasma
collections in the UK and thus carried a
substantially lower Hepatitis B and
non-a non-b hepatitis risk and he
explains
um then
further down about 12 or so lines down
factor eight concentrates on the other
hand in particular U.S commercial
material from Paid donors were derived
from large donor pools and then he gives
some figures and imparted a
substantially higher risk of hepatitis
and so that that's the first observation
Professor Savage makes over the next
page
um picking it up
um about six lines down he says in
relation to um the administration of
armor Factory in March of 1981 no
explanation whatsoever was given as to
why cryo precipitate or even NHS factor
eight concentrate were not used or even
if they were not available in the
hospital at the time
furthermore there's no documentation as
to whether advice in the choice of
therapeutic product was sort from a
senior colleague or whether
authorization was requested or given to
administer this U.S material treatment
of the child with the U.S product in
view of the prevailing recommendations
and Hospital policy the lack of suitable
documentation and in the absence of
authorization was negligent and towards
the bottom then of the next page
and I'll just pick it up in the last few
lines having described the ongoing use
of armor concentrates Professor Savage
says this in the last four lines this
policy was pursued with no reference to
the availability of NHS concentrate at
the hospital in the face of growing
concern and increasing information in
the public and medical press that aids
was transmitted by Blood products
um and then if we go to page nine last
of all
um there is this observation from
Professor Savage it would seem that
armor was the sole supplier of
commercial Factory to Birmingham
Children's Hospital at that time and Dr
Hill was purchasing large amounts of low
Unity files at any one time
however instead of allocating an
individual small group of patients on
any one batch to ensure long-term
continuity of management of such cases
on the same batch it would seem that
with a few exceptions the vast majority
of Dr Hill's patients received the same
batch over a few months until the batch
was used up
this rather bizarre approach to patient
management resulted in the child
receiving a relatively large number of
batches of vials of material containing
few units in a remarkably short time the
therapeutic management of this child
during
1981-84 but particularly during 1981 and
1982 was negligent and undoubtedly the
ill-conceived use of armor factor 8 must
be held responsible for the infection of
the child with the eight virus
so that's Dr Savage's Professor Savage's
report and and we can see from this that
Jonathan was treated sometimes with
cryoprecipitate it would appear
perfectly satisfactorily is that is that
your recollection
um but then treated with armor Factory
for no obvious reason
this policy told me was his policy which
was that children were kept to the same
batch where wherever possible which
doesn't seem to have happened in this
case and the only way I can explain it
to myself is that I think it was sister
Marion who consistently gave cryo
although I haven't been back through the
records to check
um but out of hours treatment the
management of Junior doctors and their
prescription of treatment
um seems completely random
and
we're going to come shortly to a meeting
that you attended at the hospital and in
I think 1984 late 1984 but before we get
to that had you at any point during
these years been given any advice or
information about the possible risks in
terms of transmission of AIDS
no
um
Edward's treatment at this time I think
was with cryoprecipitate is that is that
correct it was
um although he did have a mix of
treatment in his early life too I have a
little information about that
um yeah so I don't think there's a
different pattern
now
um
so a meeting then took place
um and I think doing the best you can
you think it was the Autumn of 1984 yes
um what can you recall about that
meeting
the parents there that was it was a sort
of overwhelming walking into the room
and seeing how many people are affected
um and I can remember still where I was
sitting in relation to the platform you
know there's some things that are burnt
on my mind
uh and we were told that
um there was sort of Preamble about htl
V3 and what what it was and what the
understanding was from the um from Dr
Hill at the time
and I think there was a few others from
his team there but I can't remember who
and he told us that they had been
testing the stored samples of which they
had many because they've been doing
research on um other issues to do with
immuno
um suppression
and that they knew which boys had
Acquired hdlv3 and which hadn't
um but my memory is quite clear that
they didn't they encouraged us not to
ask unless we felt it we really needed
to know because they were worried that
we would treat the boys differently if
we knew that they had hdlv3 and that
wouldn't be good for them so the the is
it right to understand
um that the message you recall is that
as parents it would be better not to
know that was what I took away from it
yeah
um
uh and you put it this way in in
um your statement we were invited to ask
for a personal meeting with Dr Hill if
we wanted to know whether or not our
children had HIV however we were
discouraged from asking as he said he
was concerned that our knowing of a
positive diagnosis would change our
relationship with our child there was no
treatment and nothing could be done
about the results yeah
um now a few days after that meeting you
um you went into one of the treatment
rooms and you saw a list of names on the
refrigerator what can you tell us about
that I've taken one of the boys in for
some treatment and it was a very small
treatment room with a couple of big
fridges in my colleagues will remember
and on the tall fridge door there was a
list pinned to the outside of the French
door with a list of boys names on and
because I had spent so much time over
the previous few years at the hospital
and most of the boys weren't on
prophylactic treatment so they were
there too I knew which boys were big
users of factor item which weren't
and I had understood from the meeting
that Richard would have been infected
with
hdlv3 as it was because of the volume he
was getting through I think he had
um over 450 000 international units
during his short time at the Children's
Hospital before he died
um so and when his name was there that
sort of confirmed that that might be but
then I saw Jonathan's name
and that was completely unexpected
and what you understood this to be a
list of the boys who had two episodes
yeah I was pretty certain
so I've been asked to see Dr Hill
um and what what did Dr Hill tell you he
told me that both boys were infected but
Edward wasn't
and Edward's name had not been on it not
been on the list
um
is it right to understand that you
hadn't been aware before the October
meeting that there was testing being
undertaken on the boys
um it's a difficult one that I don't
think I knew that it was testing there
was testing going on it didn't surprise
me when we were told they had been
tested and because there was you know
frequent blood tests being taken quite
often that we didn't know what they were
being taken for and repeatedly of about
100 mils which adds a little boys is
quite a lot and because there was
research going on in the unit and um
I was comfortable with that because I
wanted them to find out how to get make
things better
um but we weren't told what they were
being tested for
so you knew the blood was being taken
you knew there were a variety of tests
but you don't think you were
specifically told and invited to consent
to an htl V3 no I'm almost certain of
that
um
how was when you were told this by Dr
Hill do you have any recollection of of
of
how the information was communicated in
the extent to which you were given
advice or guidance on on what to do
in that initial meeting no I think the
emotions just were enough to take out
without
um carrying a lot of information out
with me I don't think there was much
information available at the time
um certainly the only advice we had was
at home to
um wash everything in the hottest
possible wash and use a 10 bleach
solution
which was completely impractical in a in
a household setting
um because you don't live in a hospital
environment at home and I had little
boys
and Home Furnishings and um I even went
back and asked what to do about that and
was told that it wasn't important
um you you've learned from the
retrospective testing of stored samples
that were undertaken that Richard was
infected
um in all likelihood between August and
November of 1983. is that right
and that Jonathan was infected between
February 1981 and may of 1983. yeah so
that first armor transfusion may have
carried the virus when he was one
and as you've described in your
statement and referred to a moment ago
you you had particular concerns about
how to manage in a home environment with
at that point three children one of whom
of course was not infected with HIV and
in circumstances in which is this like
Richard in particular had very heavy
bleeds so there would be blood in in the
home environment almost every morning
Richard had had a nosebleed overnight
and he'd wake up with a cow Pat of blood
on his pillow and it would all be
mattered in his hair and face
um he used to drink from a feeder Beaker
and put it down in his smaller brothers
and pick it up you know with blood
trickling down his face from time to
time and so we lived in an environment
where if HIV was easy to transmit in a
family setting it would be likely to be
transmitted in hours
and and again just picking up on on the
evidence you gave him a minute or two
ago you you say you recall going back to
um the hospital this is in your
statement
um and asking if personal would kill HIV
um and the nurse said there are far more
important things to research than that
yes
the nursing system was very helpful yes
Marion Gregory was an absolute treasure
um and I think uh I don't know how I
would have coped with these particular
three small boys and their difficulties
had it not been for her the boys called
her auntie Marion
um and she had a a cupboard full of toys
that were refreshed all the time so the
boys went to the hospital to see what
the new toys were rather than the
treatment and in that way just
normalized our experience to an extent
um as well as giving me huge personal
support and then in in that time after
you had learned that both Richard and
Jonathan had been infected with HIV so
October 84 over the next couple of years
to what extent did you have ongoing
dealings with Dr Hill prior to Richard
them becoming ill and the last couple of
weeks of Richard's life Dr Hill was a
very assiduous doctor I would say we had
and I used to be annoyed about it at the
time he used to have quarterly
outpatient appointments for all three
boys
that would always run over and to manage
three boys in an outpatient clinic
setting especially one with disabilities
who I couldn't keep in his wheelchair
was really hard work and I thought
because we were being seen at the
hospital so often it was more than was
necessary to keep a tab on on what was
going on so we saw him often
and when Richard was in hospital he
would be there all hours around the day
and night weekends and weeks and so it
we didn't have any lack of attention
um at the end of April 1986 Richard
became very ill
and he was admitted to hospital
um and is it right to understand the
thinking was that uh this um was uh HIV
and that Richard was a dying
um from AIDS
it was yeah it was a bit early they
couldn't find a reason for his
unconscious state
and so Dr Hill had heard about a patient
in France that had toxoplasmosis of the
brain as a result of HIV infection and
he his theory was this thesis wasn't
that was what was happening to Richard
and
Richard was then in in hospital for
about a couple of weeks yes and his
condition his condition deteriorated it
did
and and then he he died mid-may 1986 yes
um you've described how he was and
during those last couple of weeks in
your statement is there anything you
want to tell us about it it's entirely a
matter for you the extent to which you'd
want to talk about it or not
um it felt very unreal at the time
because Richard had been so desperately
ill through brain beads and Encephalitis
and so on through his life
um that it wasn't really until some
months after he died
emotionally accepted that he wasn't
coming back but the hospital looked
after us really well through that period
I think he was the first child to die
thought to be dying with AIDS in the
hospital
and
we never felt that there was anything
untoward about them caring for him so
gloves on aprons a mask would be worn
but never space suits and people would
come in and talk to us without gowning
up
um yeah that it was exemplary the way
they looked after us but the tumor of
Richard's death was exacerbated by
events in the immediate aftermath of the
death it was can you tell us about that
well the Children's Hospital at the time
had since moved didn't have facilities
to do a post-mortem on an infected child
and so they needed to use the facilities
of the coroner's office
so Dr Hill got in touch with the coroner
and asked for the to do the post-mortem
there and the coroner in Dr Hill's words
became very excited at the idea that an
htl V3 positive boy had died on his
patch and he released a state Richard
died at ten to nine in the morning and
he released a statement to the press the
coroner that morning before the
postmortem was done to say that a child
known to be HDL V3 positive had died and
thought to have died of AIDS in
Birmingham Children's Hospital
the media loved it at the time because
it was still a very stigma oriented
illness and so there was a Feeding
Frenzy
around the fact and because Richard well
boys with hemophilia don't die every day
when they're eight and Richard's age was
given
um everybody who knew us knew that
Richard had HDL B3
um and we can see if we just look at
WITN 1021009
we go to the second page
we can see some examples of of press
reporting we don't need to look at the
text but the headlines tell us the story
Hospital AIDS probe or little boy's
death AIDS Theory over death and then
there's and what's effectively is that a
correction AIDS virus not to blame
because as I understand it the
post-mortem revealed that Richard
um had died of a bleed on the brain it
was a clot down in the stem of his brain
yeah
um
what was we can take that down thank you
what what how did
the boys schools react to their
infection I think you had a range of
experiences I did all three boys were at
different schools
Richard was at a special school
um and his head teacher had lost her
child at 15 and for so phoned when she
heard Richard had died
um with severe sincere condolences
it was about midday and then when the
first edition of the lunchtime news came
out she phoned me back and was so
abusive on the phone
um that I put you know all everybody's
lives at risk in the school because I
hadn't told them for very good reason
which I do mention in my statement
um and um I just had to put the phone
down oh it was just shocking
and then um Jonathan's school
didn't say anything
um but the Headmaster asked me some
weeks later if Jonathan was all right
and I knew I thought I knew what he was
asking me but I answered the question he
actually asked and I said yes he's fine
um because I didn't want to talk about
it so I didn't think it was necessary
because he wasn't bleeding at school
and Edwards School the headmistry Scott
in touch with me and said the parents
have been asking questions and were
quite concerned about having Edward in
the class whether it was safe for their
children and she agreed with me what she
should say and that she should call a
meeting to the parents and it completely
calmed it down and they wrote to me a
lovely composite letter and sent a
donation to Philip to Richard's memorial
fund
um which you know so you couldn't have a
wider range of responses really in one
one town
um
more broadly how how did you as a family
experience the stigmatizing effect of of
AIDS an htl V3 we didn't really feel the
stigma
too much I mean it was a frightening
thing and we knew we wouldn't talk about
it outside a very very tight Circle when
we first heard about it
um but it wasn't difficult for the
family really because our friends were
fabulous until
the publicity
and then everything changed
um because there were no the play dates
just stopped coming for the boys
um we send invites out for boys birthday
parties and nobody would turn up or one
or two
um the school stopped stimulating
Jonathan
um and he was a bright you know very
very capable boy and it was just alive
to daydream because they felt sorry for
him
uh Edward's mental health was really
really badly affected by Richard dying
and there was no help at all for that
uh and immediately on the death
um we the the media were trying to find
out from the hospital who we were
and we got these little boys who were
four and six
um
so we went to friends on the south coast
Who provided us respite for two weeks
while the media frenzy died down uh and
thereafter we moved the boys schools to
um a primary school 10 ish miles away
where nobody would recognize our history
and they could carry on their childhood
as normal
and you you also observe in your
statement that there was
um
that there were known to be a number of
other children
um
treated at Birmingham Children's
Hospital also infected with HIV and
obviously we'll be hearing further
Evidence about that today
um and then there would be deaths and
funerals
they're sort of increased that sort of
stepped up the frequency of them and
because we as parents knew each other
very well we went to the funerals
and it just felt like there was this
wave of death and every time I went to a
funeral we would all be in tears and we
would be anticipating our children our
own children dying
um but there was quite a lot of mutual
support between parents who were in that
group which was very helpful and
continued for a while
and just one observation if I pick up on
in your statement I'll just read a
paragraph from your statement you say
this one question in my mind is what
incentives if any doctors were given to
limit product use or to use a particular
product
on one occasion I remember a set of
white leather suitcases appearing in the
treatment room and someone mentioned
that these have been provided by a drug
representative
I wondered what really influenced
treatment choices
it's still a question
I don't know the answer
now
Jonathan at this point in time when
Richard died he didn't know his own
diagnosis
and it was a few years later I think
when Jonathan was about 10.
that
um you decided that he should be told
and and your your husband told Jonathan
um the position
you describe that as you I think you're
certainly watching your husband and
Jonathan in the garden here how
agonizing that discussion was yeah
yeah Jonathan had started to ask for
grown-up conversations
and we knew we needed to tell him at
some point and there were stuff around
in the in the media that Jonathan was
picking up
and so we decided it was probably the
best time to tell him before he got into
adolescence
um and so was one of these sort of
man-to-man conversations he was asking
for and Phil took him into the garden
and had a chat about it
um but before I ask you a little more
about Jonathan and and Edwards
um you brought litigation when
Jonathan's behalf against the health
authority
um and that went the the global HIV
hemophilia litigation having settled in
the inquiries had evidence about that
you the individual case against the
health authority actually went to court
it did
um uh and um
you gave evidence to the court on the
second day of the hearing yes and on the
third day of the hearing Dr Hill was due
to give evidence but what happened
before Dr Hill gave evidence well first
thing in the morning
um my QC approached me and said that
they'd had an offer to settle with the
Children's Hospital
and he said it was a total gamble
because he had no idea how Dr Hill would
respond to questions
uh and the settlement that they'd
offered was 75 000 pounds and my intent
in taking the action was really to make
sure that Jonathan could have a home if
he was to be lucky enough to grow up
and I at that point 75 000 pounds would
have been enough to have brought him a
small house of his own
so I decided I'd achieve my objective
and because we were so hugely dependent
on the Children's Hospital
for treatment and I respected Dr Hill at
that time and I didn't want him to be
cross-questioned I wanted to respect to
protect that relationship I decided that
we should settle and so he was never
cross-questioned in in the high court
we'll we'll look in a moment at the
statement he provided for that
litigation
um just just before we do that however
can I ask you about something you again
you're saying in your statement it was a
a time later you you or the family
encountered someone who'd also worked at
the Children's Hospital in a more Junior
capacity yes well it was my
father-in-law he used to repair antique
clocks as a hobby after he retired
and he went to a house near to where he
lives and
the owner of the clock said to him
are you related to Elizabeth buggins
and they said yes he said I was a junior
doctor at the hospital
when Elizabeth took the court case
and she should never have settled
now I only have that from my
father-in-law so it's second-hand
information and I tried to find the
doctor concerned who I think has retired
since
but he told my father-in-law so I
understand that he went he went abroad
to work because he felt so uncomfortable
about the way treatment was managed
and the reason Emmy thought that you
shouldn't have settled was shouldn't
have settled for that sum because in
reality Jonathan should have been
awarded a much greater substantially
more yeah
and then again just before we look at
the the
um the statement from from Dr Hill
um
not long after since 1993 and you've
told us you you one of the reasons you
um also thought favorably of the
settlement offer was you didn't want to
impair the relationship with Dr Hill
because you had two children who
continued to be treated undertale but
you then got a letter from Dr Hill
refusing to continue to treat the
children
yes it was early in very early in 1980
93 so the year after the court case
and he asked us to take our children for
treatment to another Center and did he
explain why
I have copies of the letters at home
which I could Supply but um I don't have
that in my mind I know there was some
allegation made I think by my lawyers
that there was a note in Richard in
Jonathan's notes it's a handwritten note
that looked as if it may have not been
added contemporaneously and that really
upset Dr Hill and there's a letter back
from me following Dr Hill's letter
saying I'm really sorry that the
allegation was made
um and then I spent the next year trying
to
persuade him that we still did trust him
because it was a it turned into an issue
of how much did we trust him to treat
the boys and I think how much he trusted
us
and I involved a huge range of people
because I having worked in the Health
Service I knew how the structures hung
together so I went first to the hospital
management and asked them to intervene
and mediate
um I then went to the the local area
health authority Dr Bernard Crump was
the the lead there he refused to get
involved
um the Children's Hospital supported Dr
Hill and said now you have to find
somewhere else I went to Professor Rod
Griffis who was the regional director of
Public Health and I think the health of
the regional Arrangements held the
doctor's Consultants contracts at that
time
um and he worked with us really hard to
try and mediate and make arrangements
um but by the Christmas of that year so
a whole year we hadn't had outpatient
appointments for the boys
um we had emergency treatment only
and I'd arranged through my professional
contacts for the HIV specialist at
heartlands hospital to do blood tests on
Jonathan so that we could keep track of
how HIV was affecting him under a
pseudonym so that it wouldn't be
recognized
yes that was a hugely difficult time and
because we weren't on prophylaxis we
were at the hospital every few days and
I couldn't imagine with three children
because Rosie had been born by that time
how
um
we could manage going to Liverpool or
Oxford which was where we were trying to
be persuaded to go and still manage any
sort of life or any sort of education
for the children
and so I felt completely stuck
and because Dr Hill had done Dr Savage
had done the expert report and we came
across the clinical nurse specialist
from there at our hemophilia Society
conference
um it was suggested that we should go
and see Dr Savage which we did
and I thought it was going to be really
really hard to manage life like that and
we probably need to move house and in
natural fact because they had
prophylaxis because the factor was
delivered up to our house because they
only wanted to see them every six months
it life became substantially easier and
much less painful and traumatic for the
children
say I'm going to look now at the
statement that Dr Hill provided in in
Jonathan's litigation
um and as well as dealing with aspects
of Jonathan's care it is Dr Hill's
perspective on his approach to treatment
and therefore of of of wider interest
and importance
um as well for those whose children were
treated at the Children's Hospital so
Lawrence could we have w-i-t-n1021
zero two four
and we can see it's a statement from Dr
Hale
um the date of the statement is April
the 11th 1992.
um that's later in the document he gives
some backgrounds about the the Pediatric
um Center paragraph two refers to it
being the largest Pediatric Center for
hemophiliacs in the country
um between 50 and 70 severe hemophiliacs
that registered and then he describes a
regular Medical cover being provided by
senior house offices in paragraph three
and and then
um if we go to the top of the next page
there is reference to the top of the
page to the quarterly assessments that
you've referred to Elizabeth and then he
says this
the treatment policy of the unit was to
provide a treatment service that allowed
replacement therapy to be given as early
as possible to treat spontaneous
hemorrhages so that potential short-term
and long-term damage to joints and
muscles could be minimized our means to
do this was dependent on supplies of
factor concentrates with regard to
hemophilia a the factor concentrates
available for use for cryoprecipitate
NHS or commercial factor 8 concentrates
the amounts of these available at any
point in time was variable with supplies
of NHS factor 8 being the least
available
cryoprecipitate is a product that was
suitable for use in the hemophilia unit
but not favored for use at home because
many many patients particularly children
can have anaphylactic reactions to this
product cry precipitate was therefore
used only for treatment on demand in the
hemophilia unit
particularly for newly presented
patients until it was clear whether or
not they would require regular treatment
as it was known that infrequently
treated or mildly affected hemophiliacs
were more at risk of contracting
hepatitis B and becoming Hepatitis B
carriers if treated with factor 8
concentrates rather than cryoprecipitate
patients of younger age prior to
training for home therapy were therefore
likely to be treated more frequently
with cryoprecipitate however if
cryoprecipitous have an appropriate ABA
blood group or if the patient had had
reactions to cryoprecipitate or one was
treating a major bleed or required a
smaller volume product back to eight
concentrates were more likely to be used
the type of concentrate will be
determined by availability but the unit
tried if possible to maintain a given
patient on either NHS or commercial
concentrates uh in late 1976 in an
attempt to control hemophilia bleeds and
to give patients a better quality of
life home therapy programs were
introduced this therefore required
increased amounts of factor concentrate
and Commercial concentrates were more
available than NHS concentrates and then
he says this
about his knowledge of risk I was well
aware of the existence of viruses
causing serum hepatitis from the time
that I came to the Birmingham Children's
Hospital that was in 1976 he says
elsewhere in the statement I was aware
that concentrates made from pooled
plasma carried a greater risk of
hepatitis than blood products made from
single donors and we closely monitored
our patients for jaundice
test for screening for Hepatitis B were
introduced in the UK in the mid-1970s
and these tests were conducted on our
patients I was aware of the AIDS in
German homosexuals from 1979 1980 from
my dealings with other patients I became
aware of the possibility of AIDS being a
condition encountered in hemophiliacs in
early 1983 but I had no knowledge of
whether the condition was associated
with a virus infection or could be
associated with imported factor 8
concentrates I was certainly conscious
that there was a similarity between
hemophiliacs and homosexuals in that
both had an increased risk of hepatitis
but there were many theories about its
cause including that it might be related
to an increased antigen load it was not
thought that there was any call for any
treatment alteration because of the
association between hemophilia and AIDS
based on information available in 1983
and to withhold the treatment of acute
hemorrhages was considered more
dangerous
um there's then a reference in the next
paragraph to a tuberculosis outbreak in
the children's hospital I'm not going to
read through that
if we go to the bottom of the next page
please
last paragraph
and he says this the treatment policy
that I had in the unit for severe
hemophiliacs was to treat newly
diagnosed infants initially with
cryoprecipitate and then he refers to
what he'd set out above
and then top of the next page
he makes this statement
cryoprecipitate was not appropriate for
use at home because it had to be stored
under strict temperature conditions in a
deep freeze or it would be dangerous to
use and the risk of anaphylaxis
occurring without immediate Medical
Health these risks outweigh the
advantages of cryoprecipitate to produce
donor exposure and making factor a
concentrate the treatment of choice for
children once they were on home
treatment
a factory concentrate was also the
treatment of choice if a patient had any
anaphylactic reaction to cry precipitate
or when one wished to be certain of a
definite rather than expected rise in
factor eight units and then paragraph 14
tells us that normally we would consider
a patient for home therapy at about
three years of age although it was not
uncommon for it to be earlier
particularly as our unit was very
skillful at training patients and their
parents to be able to administer
factorate at home
um he then refers in the next paragraph
to um
on the job training for senior house
officers and a written instructional
protocol and he refers to attaching that
document and indeed we we have that
document which we'll look at in a moment
um he asserts um that it the document
sets out the fact that cryoprecipitate
is the most frequently used material and
that freeze dried factorators reserved
for patients who've had severe
anaphylactic reactions to
cryoprecipitate that cannot be
controlled and and then if we go over
the page
and he then
um details Jonathan's treatment
um and
um uh hits forward
thoughts about the the the treatment and
if we pick up I'm not going to read it
all and but we can see about eight lines
into this paragraph eight or nine lines
he refers to Jonathan being given factor
eight armor Factory on the 27th of March
1981 and he says this I cannot decipher
the signature of the Sho who treated the
plaintiff and there is no indication on
this notice to why factor eight
concentrate was given on this occasion
it could have been that no
cryoprecipitate was available or it was
felt more convenient to give factor
eight concentrate or to ensure a
predicted therapeutic response and and
then he looks at a number of other um
occasions upon which Jonathan had been
given
um uh
um armor factor eight
and and
um
if we then
go over to the bottom of
I think it's page eight Lawrence please
and he makes this assertion again going
to the generalities
um of the approach to treatment the
Birmingham Children's Hospital never had
sufficient supplies of NHS Factory
concentrate to meet its needs the supply
position for the hospital in relation to
blood products between 1981 and 1985 was
and then he refers to an attached
schedule and then he says this it was my
view at the time that the NHS material
was
safer because of the lower transmission
rate of hepatitis it was a product I
would have preferred for all my patients
if I could have received enough given
the difficulty in Supply I made efforts
to ensure that the commercial product
which we received Limited
potential exposure from hepatitis
infected donors to the patients I
attempted to purchase entire batches of
concentrate so that the batches could
last much longer and I also aim for
bottles with smaller numbers of units
which were better for the size of our
patients
and then he refers to setting up a
priority system for the use of the very
limited supplies of NHS concentrate that
she says he had available and it seems
essentially to be if if there was an
anaphylactic reaction to commercial
factor eight
we then have a heading advice to parents
of the risk and he says this and
obviously be picking this up with Brenda
and Linda and due course as well it was
always my practice to keep parents
informed of risks as we knew them as
stated earlier in this statement however
we had no reason to suppose that the
treatment being given exposed the
patients to an AIDS risk at the relevant
time however we were aware of the
potential risk of the transmission of
hepatitis virus by all blood products
this risk had to be set against the risk
of leaving the hemophiliac bleeds
untreated and then he refers to aspects
of Richard's treatment
um and then if we go over the page
the assertion in the second line is the
risks of treatment and balancing these
risks against not managing the
hemophilia bleed by treatment with
concentrate was always discussed
and and
then he refers later to meetings
including I think the possibly the 1984
meeting that we've already referred to
um could we then go to the next page
briefly
I don't propose to read this out but if
we could just turn it round this is the
schedule
um that Dr Hill refers to
um and it gives the product usage so I
haven't had an opportunity yet to match
that up against information and the
annual returns but we'll certainly do
that but well the um
the presentation which you provided
on the Birmingham Children's Hospital
amongst the of the two Birmingham
hospitals
showed that in 1981
the product mainly used for inpatients
was mainly NHS product with some factor
eight
and home treatment was in mainly
commercial
1982 it was mainly factor eight armor
product some NHS and a little
cryoprecipitate
those who are at home were on mainly on
factor eight in 1983
uh the sum
cryoprecipitate
some more NHS but mainly factor eight
and in 1984
there was somewhere between 20 to 25
percent of the total product used was
NHS 70 to 75 percent uh was
um commercial
and about ones less than 1 16 was cry
precipitate
in 1985
um
the
what what you observed at the time
there's never enough NHS factor eight
for all the patients
1985
the armor suppliers were said to Be
steady there was some unheated
National Health Service product about
the demand for cry precipitation then
increased
that's what I was told yes um and that
was information drawn from the annual
returns yes and so what we'll need to do
Elizabeth having very kindly
um uh um been able to provide us with
this document is to see whether the
information Dr Hill was giving the court
matches up with what was in the annual
returns
um and then just briefly if we go to the
next page
we see the written protocol which his
statement says was a document issued to
uh a senior at house officers I'm not
going to go through the detail of it and
but it may be that um in terms of uh
it's undated but it may be describing a
state of affairs in the 1970s rather
than 1980s and I say that because if we
go to the next page please
Under The Heading dose of replacement
therapy
paragraph three says type of therapeutic
material available a cryoprecipitate
most frequently used material B freeze
dried preparation to factorate small
amounts only available
uh and so
um
that that certainly isn't the position
either described by any of the witnesses
we'll hear from today by the time we get
Beyond and the second half of the 1970s
nor is it the position that the annual
returns revealed so although it's an
undated protocol it does look as though
it really must be referring to the
position in the 1970s
yes uh Dr Hill suggested it was was the
relevant protocol at the time it is just
yes he may be wrong that's what he he
says yes it is
um so our thanks Elizabeth to you and to
Jonathan for um providing us with that
information and which is of great
assistance as we didn't have
a a full statement from Dr Hill
um let me just ask you a little then
about hepatitis C
you didn't recall discussions with Dr
Hill about hepatitis C you've told us in
your statement Jonathan asked himself to
be tested in around 94.95 and learned he
was hepatitis C positive
in relation to Edward
at the time you drafted your statement
your
um you you couldn't recall being told by
Dr Hill that Edwards had tested positive
for Hepatitis C but as I understand it
in the course of preparing for your
evidence today you found some material
which suggests that you you may have
been told yes and this is the
difficulties of memories over so many
decades and the fact that HIV was the
big worry and hepatitis was always
presented as something not to worry
about at the moment I think
um but yes there were letters
um in Edward's treatment record of
um
certainly letters to the GP that
explained that he has discussed
hepatitis with me
um because Edward has got the name right
Edward had
um periods where he was really lethargic
and not very well for some weeks and I
was quite concerned about that and
talked to Dr Hill about that and he had
abnormal liver function test results and
so
um it was likely that it was non-a non-b
and then he we were told before he left
the Children's Hospital that he was hcv
positive I think in 1992. now
um You you hadn't told Edward who'd been
profoundly distressed by Richard Staff
you you hadn't told him that Jonathan
was HIV positive no um how did Edward
learn of Jonathan's diagnosis
um it was very difficult to know what to
say when
um but we we went to Saint Thomas's
hospital for treatment following
eviction from the Children's Hospital
and it wasn't our first Clinic there it
was some months in uh we went I took
them to a clinic and a new doctor
appeared
and he walked in the room with both sets
of notes and he said to me let me get
this straight
Jonathan as HIV and Edward has hepatitis
C
in front of Edward
I think Jonathan was sitting outside but
heard the conversation
um
and what do you do in that situation so
I confirmed that he was correct I think
he couldn't understand why Jonathan had
got HIV and not hepatitis C
as well and yet Edward had hepatitis C
um and then after after we'd had the
consultation I went out and found the
doctor and explained to him
um that Edward hadn't known before
and he was he was profoundly sorry and
it was just one of those things he was
thinking hard and not thinking straight
I think yeah but I think it helped us
because it breached that difficult
decision about when to tell and Edward
was old enough at that time to be able
to keep a secret and to have a
conversation with
Jonathan
um in in terms of his own health
um uh suffered
PCP in in 1997 New Mexico neuronia
um you because not least to think of
having lost Richard you feared that was
the end for Jonathan oh yeah
um I know there's a number of people
here who've lost more than one child
um and I just I can't imagine how they
deal with that
I listened to sue last week from older
hey and my heart went out to her and
because the second time it's happening
it sort of reawakens all of the emotion
of the first time
and it was me who needed to go and see
him at St Thomas's when he was admitted
for PCP it wasn't him that needed me
um but I just had to get us trained
straight down and um and be there and I
just kept going for walks along the
Thames to cry because I didn't want to
cry in front of Jonathan
but we were very fortunate in that in a
couple of weeks he was well enough to
come home and um
he's still here
you described in your statement your
focus throughout these years
um was trying to focus on the positive
trying to keep life normal
um and you said in your statement
looking back now you don't think you
realize the full extent of the emotional
and physical impact on you all
I don't think we could have coped or had
any sort of sensible life if we'd have
wallowed is the wrong word but if we'd
have spent too much time thinking about
the difficulties
and I've I've been a very optimistic
person all my life and um I think
because I had such good support around
me it was always
just another challenge to deal with
but you you also observe in your
statement you wish there'd been access
to professional help absolutely to
enable you and your family particularly
for Edward who was just devastated he
wouldn't leave my side after Richard
died
um he wouldn't go to school he just
wanted to take some toys and play with
Richard in his box his coughing
um because for you don't have a concept
of death really and he was the one who
always tried to make Richard feel better
and they were similar mental age I think
um and from being a happy a go lucky
little boy who was always sunshine
Edward became morose difficult depressed
um he started wetting the bed again at
night which distressed him for years
afterwards
and I tried very hard to get help for
him in fact one of the letters from Dr
Hill in the notes talks about me asking
for psychiatric help
and he didn't think that was appropriate
and he wrote to the GP and told her and
said that he took he discussed some
strategy with me and um he gave me a
chart to
um a sort of gold star chart for when
Edward was dry at night and things like
that to try and encourage him and I
found a friend who was a a lay counselor
who said that she would try and talk to
him to try and help him because at four
you don't have the language to describe
how you're feeling
and she spent quite some time with him
over a period of months taking him for
walks in the Parks and playing games
with them and try and get him to talk
and she said to me this isn't I can't do
this she said I've been trying to work
with adults on a lay basis she said and
I don't think I'm making any progress so
I went back to the hospital and asked
for some help
but there was just none available and we
saw Edward from being this confident
little boy
just fluff nearly all of his exams his
piano exams as well as school things
because as soon as there was any sort of
test he froze he was he just couldn't do
it he wasn't confident
um
and he took that into his adolescent
years which you know were then
compounded by treatment for Hepatitis C
and so on and I don't think he's now the
same person that he would be had that
not
had he had the help that he needed at
that point
you told us about Richard's post-mortem
and the consequences in terms of the
media activity and so on
um but you've also recently seen a
letter in Richard's medical notes
um are you content for us to look at
that yes it's WITN one zero two one zero
one two
second page piece
and it says it's from a neuropathologist
it's May 1987 to Dr Hill
um refers to the home of his pathologist
Dr Ackland and says in relation to
Richard he died last year Dr Atkins
kindly let me have the brain as I
understand he was hiv-positive I've got
sections which are really quite
interesting but difficult to interpret
and I wondered if it's possible to have
a look at the notes of only a scanty
clinical history
now you you'd given consent for there to
be a limited post-mortem yeah but is it
right you did not know that there were
um
organs or or tissue elsewhere we we
thought because the um coroner wanted a
more extensive post-mortem and we wanted
to support the learning about what this
disease was thinking it was HIV at the
time
um I don't think we would have objected
but not knowing that his whole brain
went somewhere else particularly to the
place where the the consultant
pediatrician in Wolverhampton wouldn't
send Richard when he first Had a Brain
problem sent him to Alder hay he was 100
miles away instead because he hadn't
confidence in the capability of
Neurology in children it just it just
jumped out at me when I saw it in the
notes and it's the lack of case it's
lack of consent it's the lack of knowing
and having understood from the Bristol
inquiry the consequences of samples
being everywhere I guess it's no longer
there but I don't know
um
Elizabeth I'm not going to ask you in
detail about matters relating to
Jonathan and Edward's ongoing health
they are both I think going to be able
to provide their own statements to the
aquarium and we have a statement from
your daughter too which describes the
impact upon the family from her
perspective
um just wanted to pick up on a couple of
points though if I may the first is in
your statement you refer to your guilt
at giving the boys hemophilia I don't
think I'm alone in that with the
carriers of Hemophilia
um not that I could do anything about it
um but it is you would never wish
something like that on your children and
particularly because I wasn't certain I
was a carrier until I'd had the two
um you know I couldn't have prevented it
and Edward I felt very embarrassed about
when he was diagnosed with it
um but yes so I felt an added
responsibility I think to try and make
life as good as I could for them despite
that
and and then the final points I just
wanted to ask about the present purposes
was about an issue relating to the
Skipton fund and Richard you made an
application
um to the Skipton fund
um obviously a number of years after
Richard's death which was turned down it
was because
um
having died at such a young age and
before tests were available for
Hepatitis C
you couldn't prove that he had been
infected with hepatitis C
and
you then I think after you heard some of
the evidence given to this inquiry about
the Skipton and eibss from Nick fish and
from Professor Thomas
you made a further application can you
just tell us about that
yes I applied in 2011 when it became
possible to apply for people who
deceased and that was turned down as you
say
uh and I was so upset when it was turned
down I I can remember scrumping all the
paper up and putting it on the fire
um because it was just like you sort of
raise your expectations and then swipe
that's it and I didn't know what more I
could do because the evidence isn't
there
um and yet it had been
um presented to me as if they were hccv
positive or have been exposed to hcv
then you were eligible for the twenty
thousand not that they had to have
evidence of chronic illness so I thought
well that's it you know didn't pay any
more attention to it until I heard the
evidence that you mentioned
and then I thought well this isn't right
so I um got the information again that I
I that's right I'd applied for the notes
Richard's medical records and I saw
copies of the application in Richard's
notes uh and Dr Williams
letter to Skipton on my behalf that you
had to supply as part of the pack
originally
so I thought I would write to Mr Fish
and say you said this to the infected
blood inquiry and this is the
application that I made and please will
you reconsider and I had a letter back
from
um the support scheme saying you need to
fill in a new form and you need to send
it to the children's hospital and they
need to write to us again otherwise we
can't consider it we can't deal with it
as an appeal
and so I didn't want to trouble the
children's hospital again we were in the
middle of covid and they were far too
busy anyway and there was no new
information because I'd had a look at
the records by then
um so I couldn't see any appointing in
reapplying
so it sort of sits like that really in
that
um
I'm no further forward they won't
consider it until there's further
Evidence there is no further evidence to
have and yet Richard through his life
just at Birmingham Children's Hospital
so this isn't around the brain
operations
had I reckon from my best translation of
the medical notes at least 104 units of
blood in his life
through the period where hepatitis C was
being acquired through blood
transfusions not blood products
as well as all of this commercial factor
eight
from the evidence that you mentioned
it's 100 likely would have had hcv
and I feel guilty again because I'm not
desperately poor and I don't need the
hundred the twenty thousand to be able
to get by next week
um but it's just this it's a sense of
Injustice you know if they were clear
about that and I only found out about
the ability to apply because other
mothers had said or they'd all applied
and I didn't know about it until I heard
from them and so I actually applied late
in the first place it's um it was just
really poorly managed and and to the
others follow the evidence that you
referred to from from Mr Fish and from
Professor Thomas was was evidence to the
effect that the approach taken by
Skipton was if you were a hemophiliac
who had been treated for
um with with Factor concentrates
um certainly from a long period of time
they worked on the assumption that you
would have happened you would have been
infected with hepatitis C and yet
Richard hadn't been treated with very
significant quantities as well as the
blood transfusions during his short life
they have rejected that the application
thank you Elizabeth I'm going to turn
next to Brenda
and ask
um Brenda to tell us about Angie
um so Angie was born in 1972. I tried it
um diagnosed with severe hemophilia a
from birth not from birth
um from around six months old I've got
hemophilia in my family my grandfather
was a hemophiliac my brother two cousins
so I knew the likelihood of me being a
carrier although I'd never been
confirmed because I don't think in those
days there were any tests to tell you
whether you were carrier or not so when
Andrew became six months and he started
to move around a bit more rolling on the
floor and things like that I I wanted to
know so I went to a family doctor
and he sent us to the Children's
Hospital to have some blood tests taken
because my theory was if he is a
hemophiliac I want him to have records
so if he needs treatment
it's going to be no delay you can it can
have the treatment so that was when we
found out it was about six to seven
months old
um and he was under the care of
Birmingham Children's Hospital and Dr
Frank Hill was the consultant yes yes
um now to start within the 1970s
um Angie was treated with
cryoprecipitate he was yes he had the
cryo when he was a baby
um for so long
but I'm not sure whether that was before
the factor 8 was
so readily available
because I do remember the the factory
becoming a thing and we all thought oh
this is wonderful you know breakthrough
treatment we were all going to be able
to live in all more normal life
um
mainly I remember how Andrew having
factories rather than the cryo so I
think I don't think he had the cryo for
that long before he was changed onto the
factory and in the beginning he was
given the NHS factor out
um for quite a while I believe
and
then the one day we went for treatment
and he was given
this armor Factory I remember the doctor
on duty I think it was an out of hours
doctor
um because we'd be there day or night
any any time really
and the doctor said this is something
new this factoriality is new and some of
the boys have had a reaction to it
and if if he gets a slight reaction
don't worry it's nothing to worry about
so that sort of sticks it in our mind
that that was when um when changed over
and I think after that I think he was
mainly given the armor the arm effect
race but I mean I can't say for sure
about that
but when it comes to batch numbers I
don't think they ever seem to take any
care about giving the same batch numbers
you were just given what was in the in
the refrigerant you really as far as I
could could remember I don't remember
them trying to keep them in the same
batch numbers
hold
by Dr Hill or anyone else at the
hospital about the risks of hepatitis
from concentration I don't remember
hepatitis being mentioned at all to be
quite sunny it's when Andrew was a small
child
I honestly don't remember that being
mentioned I was quite shocked to hear
that they knew about it back then that
to me was something that came after that
came into our lives after the HIV
you know quite a few years after and um
what if anything were you told about the
risks of transmission leading to to AIDS
nothing really I can remember
when it all started to blow up there
were two meetings that Dr Hill called at
the hospital we could only attend one
because we were on holiday for the
second one I think it was in the Autumn
but we always used to go away in the
October half term
and I think the second one was then so
we went to the first meeting
which I remember Dr Hill stressing
that's it's in the boy's best interest
to carry on with the treatment
and and in those days we all
you know we believe doctors we put our
faith in doctors we've got a child with
an ongoing condition
we we followed what the doctors said so
you know we blindly carried on giving
the treatment but I do Wonder afterwards
why couldn't they just temporarily stop
the factory treatment while they
investigated exactly what was going on
and give us some more information you
know why why did we have to sort of
blindly carry on
and I mean Elizabeth is talking about
the guilt as well there's also the guilt
of having home treatment and me giving
Andrew the fact to write it out did I
actually administer
the dose that infected him it's quite
possible
so as well as the guilt of being the
carrier that gave him hemophilia in the
first place there's the guilt of
I could have been the one that actually
administered the the dose and at the
meeting that you did attend the the it
possibly in the Autumn of 1984
um but whenever it was it was a meeting
was it that involved other parents yes
yes just a general meeting that parents
were invited to and it was quite a few
went because obviously everyone was
concerned about things we'd been hearing
about what was happening and what could
be happening with with the ice virus so
it was well well attended and then
you're sorry no no in your statement um
you see this about the meeting and we
were told categorically by Dr Hill that
the boys would be better off continuing
to take the factory treatment and that
the hospital would not be stopping
anyone's yes yes that's right yes and do
you feel that that in relation to the
treatment that Andrew had received over
the years do you feel that you were ever
given a choice of what treatment yeah no
no I don't believe we didn't ever have a
choice of course we were all just also
grateful to have treatment we we just
you know we just
you know we wanted a better life for our
boys didn't we and the factorized was
giving our boys a better life
um how did you find out that Andrew had
been infected with HIV
well
it's really difficult we well I don't
think we were at the meeting where
doctor Hill where Elizabeth refers to Dr
Hill as saying if you want to know make
an appointment come and see me I don't
remember that so that was probably the
meeting we couldn't attend
roundabout wellander is around about 13
12 13. when we took him to the clinic at
Children's Hospital
Dr Hills suddenly started saying you
know the boys are getting older now we
need to prepare them for moving on to
the Queen Elizabeth Hospital
um you know just we'll see the boys
alone in the clinic you know you waited
waiting the uh waiting room
this is a bit strange but I thought okay
obviously the doctor knows better so
Andrew started going in to see Dr Hill
himself
and
all of a sudden Andrews Behavior changed
and he started becoming really
sort of depressed and his behavior
changed completely and he started losing
interest in school I think it was in his
probably second year at Secondary School
and couldn't understand
why the world is changing him but it
turned out that Dr Hill had told him his
HIV status at one of these meetings that
we weren't there one of the clinic you
know the clinic meetings that we weren't
there and Andrew didn't tell us what
he'd been told for quite a while
so we didn't we didn't know
but I found out it's because when Andrew
was an inpatient
I can't remember exactly how long after
he was an impatient in hospital probably
overnight a couple of nights think it
was Dental
um sitting by the bed
you just look through the notes to know
to see what's going on and then it was
written on the top of the page HIV
positive
and that was the first official
thing that I'd seen or you know been
told about this so you learned that your
child had been infected with HIV
accidentally yeah because you were
looking through the notes yes yes
um when you learned that anju had been
told by Dr Hill that he was HIV positive
without you knowing
um and without you being there
what did you think of that
quite as I was disgusted to be quite
honest
because Andrew
he became very very depressed he lost
interest in everything
and we've only started secondary school
we were first parents evening we were
told that he was a very intelligent boy
great academic future you know he could
do really well
and then all of a sudden he could see no
pointing working hard at school because
he thought he was going to die he wasn't
going to have a future
so what's the point in me in me working
hard and he stopped going to school I
didn't even realize he wasn't going to
school he was being taken to school
apparently coming out of school and and
hanging around the streets in the
daytime which we didn't know about for
so long and I think it must follow from
what you've told us that you didn't know
that he was being tested for HIV no he
didn't consent to him being no no well
they were always taking blood
for various reasons
when we went for treatment you know they
were always taking blood samples so you
know obviously Elizabeth said they've
they probably had blood stored which
apparently they did
and I think they weren't
you know they put they had blood from
the whole family because they were
looking at the connections
a bit of like the family
relationships and
I'm not sure exactly what it was for but
I wasn't surprised that they got blood
samples because they say they were
always taking it for one purpose or
another and I think it was still so
follow from your evidence that
um there was a period of time when the
hospital knew
that Andrew was HIV positive
um
you didn't no were you still involved in
his home treatment oh yes yes so you
have a son who's a hemophiliac you're
administering treatment
you
at risk yourself and you didn't know
that no no
well when we started on home treatment
they automatically give you some plastic
gloves
to handle the factory I mean I was
always under the impression that that
was to protect Andrew from Jones from me
really because you know you're
puncturing their skin you don't want to
pass anything onto that I never even
dreamed that it would work the other way
around
um
you touched on the impact on Andrew
um now in his early teens from what you
describe
um with John
stopping trying at school and so on
um
in terms of hepatitis C how how did that
diagnosis come about well that by the
time we knew about the hepatitis C
Andrew had moved on to the Queen
Elizabeth Hospital so he was no longer
under the care of the Children's
Hospital
and life was quite difficult because it
was a time that all the stories were in
EastEnders and one thing in another
about about AIDS and the you know the
news the information on the television
and everything so Andrew found that
quite difficult to cope with
and then because he was at the Queen
Elizabeth he was considered an adult now
so as parents we weren't involved at all
really and one morning A letter came for
Andrew from from the Queen Elizabeth I
posted over to him thinking it was an
appointment or something
and it was a letter stating that he was
positive for hepatitis I mean that just
came off like the time but I'm really it
just went
yeah exploded you just you know we just
couldn't believe that someone would just
be told like that in a letter
I mean that's face to face and and you
went to
um the appointment because
um Andrew now could no longer face going
to the hospital no he became the very
withdrawn
if you eat
didn't want to mix with people and you
did start at the third time refused to
go to the hospital and he had an
appointment with some liver specialists
at the hospital
and he just he just wouldn't go so I
went to this appointment because I
wanted them to know what was happening
that he just wasn't just not turning up
the the you know that just what had
happened to I mean they were they were
very nice and they listened to me but
obviously they didn't divulge any
medical information or anything but I
just felt it was something that I had to
do so that they knew exactly or tried to
tell them exactly what what was
happening
um so I'm conscious of the time I'm I'm
very happy to continue but I I know the
stenographers require breaks from time
to time
and so I'm in your hands well I I think
I'm going to ask the stenographers to
bear with this evidence it's not being
given at a very fast speed
uh so we'll we'll go on till the usual
time for breaking I think
it but they just say that if these
doctors take a different view they
should
um indicating through the usual channels
a
a
change in Andrew you went from your
sociable funny boy to someone who was
withdrawn and depressed yes yes
um he didn't want to get close to people
no no
he would have mood swings
um he became paranoid
um and you and your family fell to say
you were walking on eggshells you didn't
know what might set him off that's right
um and of course you had your daughter
yes and and it was also affected by this
well we tried to protect Michelle as
much as we could because she was eight
years younger than Andrew
and I didn't want this tragedy to affect
two children's lives so we encouraged
her to do normal things and be perfectly
honest we didn't tell her about Andrew's
HIV status
um or the hepatitis but obviously she
must have picked up that something was
going on because it was was not sort of
a normal
behavior in a household but we did try
to keep her you know protected as much
as much as we could
but so with Andre you wouldn't even tell
anyone he was a hemophiliac
because he
didn't want its associated with the HIV
and he thought if anyone knew he was the
hemophiliac they would automatically
think
he was affected of the stigma that was
attached to it
so he he just
would not make any firm friendships he'd
got lots of sort of friends but they
weren't close friends
because he was he was frightened of
everyone sort of finding out
you know and and he wouldn't let us tell
any of our friends
so we had no support we had to pretend
everything was all right with our
friends you know and put on a happy
happy smile
my mother knew because she is the
daughter of a hemophiliac and she was a
great support to me but my husband's
family didn't know all the full facts
again because Andrew didn't want want
them to know
so we were living in like this isolated
world with this volatile
I was a child but he was a teenager she
was a big a big big teenager who we
didn't know who we were going to get
when he came in the door
how he would be when he got up in the
morning we didn't know how he would be I
mean sometimes he would get so pent up
and frustrated that he'd punched the
doors and punch the wall and put his
fist through cluster board and door
panels just starting to share of
frustration of the situation that he was
in
towards the these lots of years he was
an impatient in the QE
and he became really
agitated in the ward
and he had a drip into his arm
and he was just so agitated and
his mental state was terrible and he
pulled the drip down
but he'd left the needle was in his arm
and the
the you know it was hanging out
and you just got up and marched out of
the ward
you know you just I'm going I'm going
I've got to get out of it I'm going he
marched out of the hospital and the
security people were following him and I
was following them we were all following
him down the road trying to keep him
safe
and he went down to the bottom of the
road and he was walking up and down
eventually managed to get him back into
the hospital
that he couldn't calm him down at all he
was just totally totally distressed and
Disturbed that he was taken from the
Ward to the psychiatric units of the
Queen Elizabeth Hospital where he was
forced to be kept overnight
to for his own safety I think to just
sort of try and call me calm him down
the next morning on let's go and they
did let me calm down and they did let me
bring him home
and you told us in your statement that
from from around the late teens his
physical health started to deteriorate
yes yes he became very fatigued yes yes
he would experience hallucinations yes
yes he um
he did
have hallucinations we'd be in the car
it'd be sitting in the back of the car
he suddenly be like oh what's that
what's that you know he was sort of
seeing things
I think it was all to do with his liver
um
just just totally
unpredictable really of what you know
it it was just really difficult really
difficult he also had started having
really bad nosebleeds as well towards
the end
and I mean really really bad news please
um and and there came a point when he
was he was
um under the care of the Queen Elizabeth
Hospital and you were called to the
hospital and you were told he was
terminally ill
we weren't actually told he was
terminally ill by the hospital
the QE where this rgp was invited to and
everyone else in his care myself and my
husband and our GP indeed it was our GP
that referred to him as being terminated
terminally ill and that was the first
time we'd heard these
you know put into those words
and I thought that was a bit a bit
strange really
um and then
you
um you weren't actually able to see
Andrew the day that he died because
um you tell us in your statement you're
not you're concerned you weren't given
the most accurate and up-to-date
information by the hospital so you
weren't
um able to get there to be with him
I wasn't with him at the end because he
didn't realize
how things actually work
I mean I rang up on the morning and I
was just told are we you know he's had a
comfortable night
and so I said oh right I'll be I'll be
coming be coming up and I went and
picked my mother up if I'd have known it
was so close to the end I would have
just gone straight there
and I went and picked my mother up and
she came with me and when we got to the
hospital we were too late
but I didn't realize from what they told
me that I was actually going you know it
was going to be so close
to the end and how old was Angie when he
died 24.
he didn't
um as I understand it from your
statement received treatment for
um HIV or hcv no no I I think it was a
little bit before
the antivirals became
so you know you in use
so there was with no treatment
and and did he ever receive any
counseling psychological support no no
and what about you and the rest of the
family no no I did ask my GP
and why I left Andrew died
that I felt I could do with some
counseling but he just started with well
you know time's gone by now and it's not
really appropriate and
there was nothing
but can you tell us
um about the longer term impact on you
as Angie's mum of what happened
well you know you never get over
what we've been through
um and I think you know we look at all
probably say we're a different person to
what we would have been
um I think I've sort of lived my life
since Andrew died that um
I've sort of compartmentalized it
and I've just got on with things because
I was always frightened that if I
thought about it too much the floodgates
would open and I've never shut them
so
you try to just carry on
I mean I had a 15 year old daughter
wanted her life
I don't want you to enjoy your life and
live a life
and not be you know have a life spoiled
so we concentrated on her
but it has all been bottled up
inside
but I just didn't know what else to do
and we've got some photos of Andrew is
it okay if we look at those yes yes
parents could we have those photos
please you can just tell us about them
so what's this one that's this one was
happy a Boxing Day a nuns
Andrew
smiling Michelle
's difference between them but that was
before everything you know everything
life was great everything was everyone
was happy
a nice little happy family
and that again is the holiday we were on
holiday
happy Michelle toddler Andrew
eight nine years old nine years old
enjoying himself and just living living
a lovely life
yeah that was Andrew his first year at
secondary school again just before
everything started to blow up in his
school uniform or proud and you know
the whole future in front of him
now that's later on when Andrew had
started to become ill
I think if you look at his face you can
see
there is you know he's quite quite ill
there
and that was the day when we'd um
come down to busy Grandad who was
staying in a caravan so we went through
the day and he was on the way back from
there that he started having
hallucinations in the car
as we were driving home which which were
really quite uh quite frightening and as
you can see it was quite a big a big
chat and
it could be quite sort of frightening
you know when you started having these
uh episodes
but um
I just said that's I don't really like
to look at that photograph because to me
it just looks so real on there and not
like himself
thank you
um
so we now have the evidence from Linda
you what would you wish to do well let
me let me ask ask Linda
um
we can take a break now and come back at
quarter to two if um if you'd like and
then hear your evidence then or you can
start now if you want
I don't mind carrying on
I was just getting a bit upset listening
to you I'm sorry well I I wondered
because I'd rather carry on I think okay
we'll we'll we will be taking a break in
the middle that's the only thing
are you happy about that I'm taking a
break in the middle of your evidence
um so you might prefer to have it all in
one go
uh
I'll draw the detailing one or if you'd
rather do it all in one go we'll take a
break now we'll draw
well that would eat into everyone's
lunch hour I'm told the sonographers
need a break all right well that that's
that that determines it then uh may I
thank the stereographers for for going
on to make sure that they captured all
of all of Brenda's evidence
um so we'll start at quarter to two Okay
and then you have a free run through
right to Tilly finish and just to say
I've been inviting obviously Elizabeth
and Brenda to come to return and sit sit
with Linda and
um once we've heard from Linda I just
want to pick up some general issues
about the Birmingham Children's hospital
with all three of you yes I was going to
say that there are General themes which
um Miss Richards is likely to to pick up
um with uh and take the views of the of
the three of you it's one of the great
advantages of having
three people who have such similar uh
experiences although there will be
slight differences between them
so quarter two two
thank you
foreign
earlier I
she's nice
Linda can you hear me okay yes I'm going
to ask you to tell us about your son
Michael and his treatment at the
Birmingham Children's Hospital
so Michael was born in 1969 is that
right yes that's right
and he was diagnosed with severe
hemophilia a when he was about three
years old no two two about two what can
you tell us about that
um
well you know when those start to crawl
when they're little and everything he
was getting these bad bruises with lumps
and things well our GP who I took him to
see
um he's been a family doctor and we've
never known hemophilia in our family so
you know that is what he didn't suspect
that and he used to give him vitamin C
and things like that and he even asked
me if I was knocking him about he says
I've got to ask you this and I said well
good Lord no and then anyway he retired
and um Michael would be about two we had
a new doctor a young doctor and we went
through it I went he had a swollen knee
I think it was and I took him to the the
doctors and um
he said um
well he just looked back at the records
and he asked me questions and he said I
want to send you straight up to the
hospital and he wrote a letter and he
said I want you to take this to the
hospital in Wolverhampton
so that's what I did and um
I was just amazed because they said
we've got to keep him in and it was just
taken away and I had to go home
and it was like that in those days they
didn't let you hang about you know
so I went home and I did nothing but
wait you know
I didn't know what was going on
anyway when I had to go back they took
me to one side and they said that some
he's got hemophilia and I've got to be
honest I'd never heard of it before
we found out that she was um haemophilia
uh it got hemophilia and um
then I I had him transferred from
Wolverhampton to the Birmingham
Children's to the hemophilia Department
and uh
and then if we just started to keep
going up every time he he
hurt himself in some way we would have
to go to the hospital and when they're
little they're always falling or doing
something aren't they so it was quite a
the journey every time you know but um
had to be done and and initially Michael
was treated with cryoprecipitate yes and
then um I think at a time when he had
NHS concentrate yes that's right but
then and your recollection was that it
was perhaps the early 1980s we can look
at a document in a moment but
um it was switched to U.S commercial
concentrates and it was the armor
concentrate I think that you've mainly
remembered right okay
um
I can't remember the name now you've
said it or recognize it but
were you told anything whether by Dr
Hill or anyone else at the Children's
Hospital about the risks associated with
the factor concentrates
um with the American no
well I went to the meeting that you
mentioned earlier
um
to me that's when they were all about
this virus I I hadn't really heard of
that before
so it was like
you know taking it all in and knowing
what was going on really and um
I knew it was a worry
um David was talking as though they'd
only just sort of found out that's the
way of that's the way I felt at the time
before we get to that meeting though in
it which was probably 1984.
um your son had been being treated
during the 1970s and the early 1980s so
before that meeting did anyone ever tell
you that that the concentrates might
transmit hepatitis no I was told by
Sister Marine that they would be
[Music]
um
stopping the the British one because it
was a lack of supply
so she said we're having be having it
from America
and that's all she said
so you just accept that that's it you
say so it was put on that treatment
um and I can't remember how long it was
from then to to when we had the meeting
we can look at a document
which you've exhibited to your witness
statement and it was a document filled
in I think at the time of the hemophilia
litigation
um and it's been filled in by a doctor
by reference to
um Michael's records so if we look at
WITN 1616003
and if we go to the next page
it's described as preliminary medical
legal report on Michael Anthony price
and then if we go to or we can see it
refers to documents letter of
instruction and then records from the
hospitals uncertified copies of batch
numbers from the children's hospital and
then if we go down towards the bottom of
the page
we can see there that the Doctor Who's
filled this in had had Michael's records
um and then
um we can see the words hemophilia a
severe diagnosed at three years old
cryoprecipitate
1973 to
1997. yeah and then if we go to the next
page
we look at the bottom of the page the
very bottom
we've got there the date the client was
first given factor eight or nine
concentrate
23rd of May 1977 and then if we go over
the page
we can see it says
um under the paragraph B at the top Omer
1977-83 and 1986
NHS
1978-86 including Scottish 1984 and then
Alpha which is a different commercial
product
1986 to 1987. so it looks from this as
though Michael was treated
um as sometimes with NHS product but
certainly also with the armor products
and that's what you remember from the
conversation with sister Marion that
they were going to have to switch to
that because they didn't have enough
energy and that's all I was told yeah
and do you feel you were ever given a
choice about about what treatment
Michael would receive not at that point
no no she she just said that's what was
happening
so I just accepted it you know
and and Michael according to this
document
um was on home treatment from about
1977. do you recall that yes yeah
um prior to that one he'd received
cryoprecipitate in the hospital had he
had any difficulties with the
cryoprecipitate no none
and we can take that down thank you can
you then tell us what you remember about
the meeting at the Birmingham Children's
Hospital in in 1984.
I guess uh I can't remember too many
details because it was such a lot to
take in all evening but
um they were just
um telling us that about this virus
which I'd never heard of before I've got
to be on this
[Music]
um
they were showing you things on
on boards you know like diagrams and
things of this virus and right you know
and it was a lot to take in but I knew
it sounded bad but I didn't know
exactly
I mean it wasn't in the news either then
it came on the news after about it he
built upon you know the AIDS and that
and
then it sinks in how really bad it is
but
and um if we look at your statement I'll
just read out what you say about it in
your statement Linda so you say I
believe in or around 1984 a special
meeting was held at the bch I attended
this meeting without Michael taking my
sister with me I recall it was Dr Hill
who ran the meeting in a big Hall that
was full of a mixture of doctors and
parents of children who were being
treated at the bch
Dr Hill delivered a presentation
detailing information about HIV
he went into depth saying the outbreak
was caused because the blood had been
obtained from Americans who were on
drugs or were otherwise diseased it was
never explained why this was allowed to
happen the meeting was directed at
letting the parents and patients know
that some people may be at risk of
infection they said if you want to know
whether your child was infected to ask
this was the first time I'd ever heard
of HIV or Aids so it was very worrying
they told us to look out for certain
symptoms so does that remain your your
memory of that meeting
yes yeah now you told us in your
statement that you recognized some of
the symptoms or thought you did but what
can you tell us well they did mention to
watch out if they came down with any
illnesses and Michael had granted a
fever and it worried me after because
they did mention that at the meeting
something about glandular fever so uh on
our next visit to the Children's
Hospital we have to go and see sister
Maria and so I asked her then
if Michael was all right because it was
worrying me and she said don't worry
about Michael he's fine
so after that we just took it he was
fine
and if I can go on a year and a half
that's a rough guess
I think it was about 15 or something
then about a year and a half later
probably when he was in his late 16
um
we was given the bombshell that he was
infected and yet I thought senior was
all right then going back
how come
it was given it after that why wasn't
they careful
because if they say it's all right then
they should try and keep him all right
and yet he wasn't and for a year and a
half we just thought it was fine he was
all right
and and you told us in in your statement
that this
um this occasion when you were told the
bombshell came about you you got a
letter from Dr Hill yeah
um and and you understood it was about
Michael transferring to the adult
hemophilia Center yes
um uh and so you went to the meeting
thinking that it was about that yeah and
at the end of the meeting Dr Hill as you
say in your statement dropped the
bombshell that Michael had HIV yes and
there was only me and Michael in the
room
my husband waited in the corks he
thought it was just to do with moving
hospitals say
and
well it was we both went silent I wish
now
um been told that Michael was being
tested for HIV no well
I hadn't been told but
um I suppose
I suppose I must check them but
I don't know it's complicated really
because I I just thought
it'd been obviously being tested for to
be told that he was all right
don't worry about him he's buying
so
you just carry on then thinking is all
right and through that whole year and a
half
we just thought everything was fine and
yet it obviously was still giving him
the treatment
with the infected blood you know the
infected treatment
and if we go back to that medical legal
report we looked at a few moments ago so
witn1616003
um and if we go to page five
and I'm looking at this because we don't
have Michael's records but we have this
report that you've exhibited to your
statement that was based on Michael's
records and and then the question at the
top of the page is about on the date on
which a fir the first blood test carried
out that produced an HIV positive result
and the answer is given first sample
1984 retrospectively tested but report
date not given first fully dated result
21st of February 1986 sampled so I think
that's the date the sample's taken and
then the report comes back 13th of March
86.
zero conversion occurred in or before
1984 and then question 10 on what date
did the records show that the client was
notified of his HIV positive condition
24th of October 1986.
so first of all Linda that that
reference there to October 1986 that
that's consistent with your recollection
of it being a year and a half or more
after that meeting at which you were
told right
um but this document suggests that
um testing at some point was carried out
on a sample of Michael's blood from 1984
and suggesting that he
um and the result was positive as at
1984. was that something you were ever
told at the time
no no
um
we we can take that down thank you when
when you were given this bombshell news
and in the weeks and months that
followed did you receive any support or
advice from the hospital
no
no not concerning that no
were you just well we moved to a
different hospital then do you move to
the queen when they dropped the
bombshell I never saw him again
we went to the Queen Elizabeth and we
was under um
well it was under Dr Wilde for quite
some while
and
you say in your statement
reflecting on the way in which you were
told about
Michael's diagnosis at this in the way
in which you've described that you felt
and still feel as though you'd been lied
to
well I do yeah well I
well for some time I thought well
I was told it was all right was that a
film
I don't know
[Music]
um
if it was well that was wrong obviously
um and then if if it was the truth then
why did they carry on giving it him and
that was what's going in my mind all the
while
um
Michael was
also infected with hepatitis C yes but
you learned about that rather later how
did that come about
[Music]
um
well it was just by after Michael had
passed away I had to go back to the
children back to the QE for some reason
I can't remember now but I was on the
car park just walking across and one of
the doctors that knew Michael a lady
doctor I don't know her name
um she she saw me on come over to give
her condolences and that you know and
and in the conversation she just said
well of course he was hepatitis C
positive as well well I never knew if I
hadn't have met her on that car park I
wouldn't have known
can you tell us
um how Michael's health
deteriorate it as he got older
well he used to
fatigue lack of energy
um
I used to get boats of diarrhea a lot
and um
uh occasional sickness
and you always used to say EAA to Zoe
got the flu all the while that sort of
feeling all the while
and it gradually started to lose weight
you know and wasn't eating like you used
to
um
as it got nearer to when it was really
really poorly he used to keep being sick
diarrhea was bad
uh
they just felt really ill all over but
he did have a lot of things before that
certain things cropped up he had
pancreatitis
which I just presumed it was to do with
the HIV but thinking about it after it
could have been connected to the
hepatitis C
but I didn't know he got it then did I
so I just assumed it was to do the HIV
um and he had a bout of um terrible
headaches for
oh well over a year
they were so bad it was on Morphine
Morphine tablets every day quite High
to to take these paintings away
and then the one day he said just swells
it was twice the size of what it should
have been and he had he has to stay in a
hospital and
um
I didn't think I think that they they
thought that he wasn't going to last
very long but he did get over that
actually I don't know how but he did and
that gradually went down
um
we had psoriasis in his scalp you know
but through stress and worry you know
um so they had a lot of things really
um
with the headaches and then he he did
get meningitis at the end passed with
meningitis
and
being the effect on him the teenage boy
is 16 years old learning that he had
this diagnosis how did that impact upon
Him mentally
well at first
it's you can tell it just knocked him
for six really and he that's when he had
the psoriasis not long after that
um
he went very quiet uh
and he he never really told me exactly
how he felt he he sort of kept it in you
know but he said he didn't want he
didn't want anybody in the family to
know
at first and he said he definitely
didn't want his Nan to know but they
were very close and she was um uh well
she's nearly in her 80s you know so
anyway
um
we did tell the close family in the end
and um but he never told any friends
and um that's the way he wanted to keep
it but um the family were very good and
they kept it into the family you know
but um
as time went on he did seem to cope
in his own way and I'm very proud of him
in that way but what he how he coped was
he able to work
he did have he did have one job
um he didn't really want to do it he
couldn't see the point
but he did go he worked for the um in
the council offices at some codswell
um I think he only worked I can't
remember how long he was there
um it could have been a year I can't
remember now but some
then he left and then
he got no interest I mean his ambition
was to be a sports photographer because
he loved taking photographs
and um he couldn't play sport himself
but he loved his football and he says
I'd love to have been a sports
photographer and he took some lovely
photos and of course in those days it
was a proper camera with the filming you
say and he did take nice lovely photos
of animals and things
but that was what he would have liked to
have done
but in
I think in his mind he thought what's
the point you know
and did he receive any treatments sorry
did he receive treatment for HIV yes I
said too and how was that
I don't know it was really well when
they uh you see I didn't go in the room
with him that day he went to see um
Dr Hill I think it was yeah he went in
on his own
and uh he looked really well he'd been
on holiday and he looked really well and
he he hadn't lost anyways or nothing and
when he come out he said I always said a
blood tester showed that um
I need to go on treatment there's some
alteration in his blood and I need to go
on treatment I've got to start on this
tablet well it was a Z2 and that's all
Michael told me he got to go on this
tablet and and he was on it for quite
some time
but then he seemed to go downhill
you know
he described in in your statement
and the last few weeks of Michael's life
he'd come back to to live with you I
think and you were looking after him yes
and then he had to go into Hospital
um you've told us about that in your
statement is there anything you you'd
like to tell us about it it's entirely a
matter for you as to
um whether you want to talk about it
well he
he was living with his girlfriend she
knew all about everything but um
I don't know there was something that
she
she just uh the one day she just told
the um a social worker
uh and the social worker spoke to me and
she said she didn't want to stay with
him anymore and she she just
I was there but I didn't know until she
said uh the girlfriend said I'm going oh
I've got to go to town and she went out
and left me alone with Michael was in
bed and the social worker
told me then that she didn't want to
stay with him anymore
and I never saw her again after that
and we have to go and tell Michael and
it was really poorly in bed and he got
upset and started to to cry
anyway we got him home we had to get him
home before she came back
so we got him home
and uh
then I I looked after him that's when he
went really downhill you know and um
I I never saw her again except for my
colostomy to go and get some money I
don't think this is in his statement but
in the statement but he said Mom will
you go to the bank and get me some money
out
and it gave me this card and when I went
it was the account was empty
but that was these the ones he used to
pay these bills on not one that he kept
his bone money
and it was empty and I'll come back and
I said there's nothing there
and he had to phone the bank well he was
he was friends with the bank with well
it was mid-shires Building Society and
he was good friends with the um
managerists and anyway she said the
money was drawn out
so that's upsetting uh anyway we went
and got the card back off her and um
uh so he was with me then and um
only just come and give me a hug and he
says Mom I'm glad to be back home with
you
and that's and I said well I'm glad to
have you back
and then in the last month of also of
Michael's night he was in the heartlands
hospital and you remained there with him
for a whole month here
yeah I slept in the chair at the side of
his bed we've got his own room and
bathroom you know
and I looked after him and
washed his hair comb his mud on his hair
being just right you know
I just looked after him here
Michael died
1995 just before his 26th birthday yeah
um you'd had to give up work I think
yourself to look after him yeah and
after Michael died your husband had to
take a Year's unpaid leave
please look after you yeah he's his boss
suggested it
he said um because Paul was worried
about leaving me on my own you know
and Michael was your only child
yeah and you said in your statement you
feel you've lost the chance to have
grandchildren
City said that's what he said to me yeah
he said you'll never be a a grandmother
and I said uh well I just said well
don't worry about it he said I didn't
know what to say to him
you know
at any point did did you or
um or your husband or Michael ever get
offered counseling or psychological
support
um I used to have a a social worker that
um her name was Jill and they were very
very close and she helped him a lot
um
but um
she used to help him with different
things but I didn't really get too
involved with that
um I think all that happened
before he came back to Missy so I wasn't
there when she came
but she kept into when she she left she
she went on a world cruise and she
always sent him postcode postcards of
where she was stopping you know
and she kept in touch with him
and were you offered any kind of support
by anybody no
no
you set in
um in your statement that
you still think about Michael every day
I do yeah every single day yeah
and you describe it in your statement as
a black cloud it's modern you describe
it in your statement as a being a black
cloud that's lived over you since that
time will your life changes and
nothing's the same anymore and you can't
just I don't know if they're just there
all the while
well not all of all obviously there's
times when you're doing things and
they're not there but every day I do
think of him yeah
and we've got some photos we'll just
look at those is that all right yeah
okay
so if we could have Linda's photos
please Lawrence
how old is he here
how old was he here do you think uh sure
I think he was probably about seven or
something I'm not sure
because I never wrote it down you don't
think of these things sometimes
and where was this that was on the beach
at both
um just outside both
um and they loved the sunshine
and he hated the rain
and yet just before he passed away there
was right it was raining
and he said to me he said would you help
me outside his room there was a corridor
with glass windows you could see outside
and he said would you take me to see the
rain
uh this is what upsets me because he
knew he wasn't going to see it again
that's all right don't worry
no it's
are you okay we've put a picture that
you
chose Michael
when he's thinner losing weight and I
think he lost more weight still after
this
you don't like looking at it but you
think it's important that people see the
reality I bought that so people could
see yeah
and then there's just a couple more
photos of Michael as a young adult and
which you exhibited to your statement so
it's
1616002 please Lawrence
so we've got we see a picture of him
there and then there's one other photo I
think next page
and another there yeah
so you can see the difference with the
where he'd lost weight
thank you Linda I'm just going to ask
the three of you now just to reflect on
a couple of themes emerging from the
evidence that you've all given to us
today
the first is
the issue of trust trusting in the
doctors
and assuming that if the treatments
being given it's safe and it's the right
treatment
I think that emerged in particular in in
your evidence but from what all three of
you have said is is that right you you
start with you Linda you trusted the
doctors well you do don't you your lives
in their hands aren't those sort of
thing and you
you believe what they say and you you've
got to trust in them you've got no
choice
then it makes you think after you know
should you trust doctors
you know it's a
night I like Linda took my eldest
Richard from Wolverhampton where he's
referred back to from Liverpool to
um
Birmingham because it was the regional
center yeah and I thought it was the
place where he would receive the most
expert care
and
um in those days they didn't expect to
be asked consent for everything because
that wasn't the customer practice at the
time so it felt like it was Auto
consenting
but it was a relationship of trust and
and they had to trust us to do the right
thing with the product particularly on
home treatment
um but absolute trust was given with
them without the most precious things we
had in them in the world
Brenda yes yes we did trust the doctors
I think we've got a child with an
ongoing condition
we put our faith in the doctors to do
the best for our children
and we believed what they said and we we
followed what they advised without
question
and looking back maybe we should have
questioned more but you didn't in those
days I think maybe people do more now
but in those days I don't think people
did did question as much as they know as
they do
but and then the second theme I wanted
to just briefly ask you about then is
the issue of choice
from the evidence all three of you have
given it doesn't appear as though any of
you were really given a choice of
treatment for your children you were you
would take your child to the hospital
and the treatment would be given yes you
didn't get told what the different risk
factors were and you weren't given a
choice
no no there's no choice nothing like
that at all
I remember with the factory we went up
and it was what was available in the
fridge on that day
yeah and I think sometimes the
professionals didn't have as much Choice
as they wanted either because there was
a constraint about the supply that I can
remember some conversations I think it
was probably around 1984.
where NHS Factor rate was so much in
demand everywhere that there wasn't
enough for the children who might have
been at the top of Dr Hill's list to be
only given factor eight rather than
commercial concentrates
um but he didn't have enough to do that
so it was a it was a sort of diagram
which involved the professionals as well
as us but clearly the consequences were
much more significant for us
and then the last theme I just again
wanted to bring out of your evidence is
the issue of how how the information was
given to you
that your sons had been infected with
HIV and we've heard from Elizabeth
seeing the names on the refrigerator in
the treatment room we've heard from you
Brenda that
um your son was told it's a relatively
young age and you were not and then
we've heard from you Linda that you and
Michael were told that told much later
on and not even knowing that that was
what the meeting was about
um the way in which you were told this
news and it can never be good news it
can never be anything other than a
terrible thing to hear but do you have
any Reflections on on the way in which
you found out
well I think
maybe the parents in the case of
children parents should have been told
before the child so that we could be
prepared to help our child accept and
take on board
that information
whereas we didn't even know he'd been
told and we couldn't understand why he
changed so much and lost interest in
everything that he loved before because
he thought he'd got no future so I think
you know we weren't given any tools to
help him cope cope with it which uh it
was really difficult I think we had our
suspicions
that he was
infected but
not taking that decision to actually
physically go and ask
was
a difficult thing to do
so maybe I did shy away from doing that
until I saw it written down in his in
his notes
um but I think it could have been
handled a lot differently you know Linda
well I think
when I was told it was done in a a cold
way
you know no emotion or
it was just like it was just reading it
off a page you know to me
uh
no feelings about it
it's the way he was
I'm afraid that doctor you know but um
I was just annoyed that's with that Gap
Auto spoke of yeah when you thought
everything was all right yeah for a year
and a half we just kept thinking oh he's
all right because they found out about
it
you know that this virus was about in in
some of the some of the treatments I I
would just presumed we were all right
for all that time
I mean I just find it's unbelievable the
way they sent a letter out telling
someone of the hepatitis infection to a
teenager
for a letter just to drop through the
letterbox
with no warning whatsoever
I think that was was pretty disgusting
to be quite honest
yeah I think the difficulty was that the
emotional and psychological impact of
that information wasn't accounted for
and the thing that I find very difficult
is that everybody who was working within
the hospital
would have known information about my
son that I didn't know and then that
undermines trust because she don't know
what people are thinking to whom you're
talking and we used to have to interact
with a lot of different health
professionals depending who was on duty
at the time we were taking the children
in
and so it was it undermined trust
generally I think which had knock-on
consequences then when we're dealing
with a much more difficult scenario
and we used to take them to the dentist
at the Children's Hospital didn't we it
was quite possible that the dentist
Dental Department knew more about our
sons than we did you know and other
agencies that you come up against as
well
because Michael was a teenager and not
known for a year and a half he could
have passed it on
could have passed it on to you or Auto
it could have passed on me even he could
have passed it on to friend you know he
did have a girlfriend then he was just
sort of leaving school but fortunately
they didn't do anything but but I mean
he could have passed it on because we
wasn't told
he was I think you said he was 16. uh he
was actually 17 when he was told
and he knew yeah or that they knew yeah
those years uh during those years did he
have a girlfriend he had one at 16
apparently you just mentioned that yeah
the girlfriend when he was at school
finishing school
um he had two girlfriends but the second
one we were talking about before but the
first one I mean
everything was fine but it might not
have been that's what I'm trying to say
and the hospital wouldn't have known
that everything was fine you know it's
like
the issue of being told
whenever he was impacted
but we don't know when it was infected
I'm I'm just going to check behind me to
see whether the legal representatives
for the witnesses have anything further
and before I ask each of the witnesses
if they have anything to add so do you
have any questions uh no I've I've asked
the only one I I had in mind when the
opportunity Heroes just a moment ago
I'm going to ask each of you then if
there's just anything you want to add
Elizabeth
yeah
I'd so like to thank you for the tenor
with which you've conducted these
inquiries because I think it has helped
me and my family a great deal
um to be looking in detail at some of
the really difficult things that are way
past in our history
and I would like to say to those in the
department of health and elsewhere from
the past that this would have been much
more useful to me if it was 20 years ago
um and part of the difficulty is in the
distance of time is accessing records
and so on which may not be so easy to
access now or may have been destroyed
and so I would like to see in any future
changes that happen as a consequence of
this inquiry
that patients or their parents for the
time being have access to all the
medical records and are able to write in
them because I think some of the
oversights and mistakes that were made
could have been corrected at the time
and therefore had less of a consequence
and I would like when
um institutions decide that they wish to
destroy records
that the family or the patient has the
opportunity to be given those records to
hold even if the institution is not
going to continue to hold them
because I think for families that have
long standing conditions and maybe
hereditary conditions there may be quite
a lot of learning available within those
records that they do wish to keep and
then if there is a long delay to a
subsequent inquiry they would have
access to those records
thank you thank you friends or is there
anything you'd like to add yeah so just
like to say that coming here today was a
big decision for me because for 25 years
I haven't spoken about this in any depth
to anyone not even my daughter
really knew the full the full facts or
or our families really my side of the
family did because there's hemophilia in
my
to talk about is I'm hoping
to get it out we'll have been
therapeutic for me and please give my
daughter a greater understanding as well
of what happened because she was eight
years younger than Andrew and we did try
to Shield her from a lot of what was
happening because I didn't want it to
blight two lives I wanted her to have
her life
and you know be successful and have a
happy life
so you know finally
she's becoming you know knows a lot more
about it and I'm hoping it will have
helped me to sort of put things to bed
maybe a little bit
and maybe I can I can talk about it a
bit more
but um I mean my mother was Andrew was
her only grandchild for eight years and
he was the light of her life
and she really suffered and she died six
months after Andrew died I think you
know it did have a big effect on her as
well
um so it's you know we can't change the
past but I'm hoping that some good
will come out of all of this now and
like Elizabeth says people in the future
won't have the same mistakes made the
things can be be handled differently
hmm
Linda is there anything you'd like to
add well I just hope that
we get some answers at the end of the
day after all this time
because it's took too long in the first
place you know
um we just need some answers and
just uh
we don't know we don't really know now
what what the answer is going to be do
we who's at fault or why did it happen
you know
and then
I just feel very proud of us on the way
he handled this
you know and
I just missing that much I don't know
what else to say it's just ruins your
life yeah
it ruins your life it does ruin your
life you you never ever get over it it's
she's like a black cloud
it's always there
in your mind always
hmm never ever goes away
thank you sir
well I I would just like to say a few
words
um
it is
you should know it's it's been deeply
impressive
to me
to sit here and to listen to you and the
way you have
first of all been here despite uh and
you've said said as much Brenda
despite your misgivings
um as it were brought yourself
to do it
and no one
who has watched could fail I think to
see that at times you have
struggled
with your own emotions each of you in
your own way
um and I'm glad that the inquiry has
been a place where you could feel that
you could
express your emotions if you wanted to
um and you have each attempted to be as
constructive
as you can be despite
everything that has happened and in many
ways that's your testimony has been the
best Testament
to your children
so thank you each of you
[Applause]
so we have one two more witnesses
take a break and just as a reminder
today's listening there will be no live
stream
um Zoom YouTube access to this
afternoon's remaining evidence yes I
shall make make an order
um I have made the order but I shall
read it out and describe it to you as I
always do when we come back at three
o'clock uh to uh to hear our next two
witnesses but in the meantime please
just remember not to take photographs
around this hearing room just in case uh
you happen to catch someone you
shouldn't
foreign